all right folks it's Sunday time for our
full daily date on stuff another side
track getting sidetracked like we
usually do except this time it's kind of
a loud yeah it's always allowed
yeah guide you some updates on what's
going on yeah
did you everything you need to talk
about not really I just today we put up
the matinee show earlier obviously where
we reviewed a tiger king and Mary Ann
and Daniel isn't real so if you haven't
seen that you should go check that out
yeah they're still talking about tiger
king a lot everybody sorry about their
faces great it's crazy everybody on my
face list it's just like did you see
they either talked about the goal was it
golden nuts golden nugget golden nuggets
or whatever yeah and so I put that up
and I finished editing the episode for
Tuesday but I'm not gonna tell anybody
it was if you're a patreon you're on
patreon yard you know what the topic is
but otherwise you have to wait and see
and also today I started working on the
the more stringent outline for faceless
villain for which is gonna cover 2000 to
2019 um it's kind of hard because like I
said it's you have to go through like
all these unsolved murder cases and what
I do is I just kind of go through pretty
much every state and I go through their
unsolved murder databases if they have
one and a lot of states do and then I
kind of go through there and be like oh
well that looks like gang-related or
that one that's like solved that one was
a robbery or whatever and so I take
those ones out and then I have to do the
same thing with like every other country
or at least every other english-speaking
country so it's taking a long time but
I'm trying to do it like one chapter at
a time you know what I mean like I'm
gonna do one chapter and it's like
decide what cases to put in there cuz I
can't put everything in there obviously
because a lot of cases you know where
people get murdered there's not really a
lot of detail about it unfortunately so
I'm just kind of trying to figure out
what to leave in what to leave out so
I've started working on that because my
goal was to start working on it April
1st
so I wanted to get a little bit ahead of
it like so I know what I'm working on
but I think that's pretty much all I had
going on today we got to go to the
liquor store only oh that's right you
got a resupply we probably should have
done that before we did this so we could
like report and see what and even know
if the liquor store is open is it it
should be probably the one next to the
grocery stores open yeah it should be I
would imagine yeah um okay yeah no so
Thomas strikes again a lot of my
predictions come true there's a certain
country where a certain kind of flu came
from I don't want to mention the name
because it'd probably get demonetised I
don't know they probably don't do any
more China China all right
the Wuhan area has blown up the Chinese
people are rioting because they're sick
of the lockdown they've overturned
police cars and they're [ __ ] up over
there which and China's a pretty is a
place where people kind of don't just
you know they obey Authority so that
goes to show you that you really can't
lock down or quarantine any population
for very long they get pissed and they
take things out of context or they think
they're being attacked so that's
happening there and they're about what a
month ahead of us and then I think it's
Sicily Sicily blew up people are ran out
of money so they started bashing in the
dam fronts of the grocery stores to try
to get food they got people that are
criminals out there with guns trying to
sell their services to knock people off
evidently and just they're they're
getting wild and Sicily I believe it was
Sicily and that that might spread to
other parts of Italy and weird shit's
happening up in New York now New York's
gonna be locked down because that's
where most of the sick people are up in
the northeastern area and
what's-his-name Cuomo said oh man to
lock us down for this period of time
this is kind or no they're also kind of
they're trying to seal off New York from
New Jersey and because they they don't
want infected people running from New
York to spread it to other areas they
got the National Guard down there going
door-to-door checking IDs
sending people back to New York and
Cuomo said this is like a declaration of
war against them so I already see how
this shit's gonna go it's like I said
before this is gonna go along partisan
lines once New York goes down you have
guys like Cuomo saying well this is
Trump trying to wipe us out which will
further accelerate the division inside
the country just get ready for folks
they're gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] with each
other and play games behind this
pandemic and they're both gonna each
side's gonna accuse each other of
different things but once one side it's
gonna keep beak used of being dirty and
spreading the virus and then the other
side is going to accuse of a trump of
trying to lock them all down and destroy
their economies and have them all in one
area where the virus can kill them
that's what that's how they're gonna
play this game it's just further
acceleration ISM unfortunate but true so
get ready to take care of yourself you
don't I mean make sure your families are
got the things that they need evidently
everybody's gonna get like a stimulus
checks I think it's 1,200 bucks that's
gonna have to be kind of regular thing
for as long as this [ __ ] happens going
on and I've been doing you know I've
been listening to a Korean doctor and
based on what he says this might
eventually evolve into basically the
seasonal flu where this keeps coming
back every season I don't think they're
ever gonna really be able to stamp this
out this is just gonna be something
that's gonna be out there forever
getting bigger and smaller and bigger
and smaller kind of like the black death
was out there for how long did he yeah
it was a few hundred few hundred years
it was out there well the worst I mean
the worst one was the first one and then
like they just had smaller smaller
smaller hombre like over the century
over about a century or so might have
been longer than have been longer so I
would I would probably think that they
would come up with some kind of a
vaccine or a treatment but I don't think
they're gonna think I don't think
they're gonna be able to get rid of this
well it's not a it's it's a flu that's
very closely related to other flus that
are
they're how they gonna stop that's what
I mean they haven't been able to like
cure any other ones or colds or anything
like that and this is just another
variation of that so I would man
quarantines are gonna have a limited
effect I think in the long run well
something like I said something like a
flu that is that contagious I mean like
I said even one that's not corona Visor
isn't as bad as this one
they are very contagious all you have to
do is like have somebody that has it
they have to breathe on somebody who
they touch something and then you touch
it like a doorknob or something and
you're gonna get it so it's like that's
kind of why these super flu type things
keep happening is because they spread so
easily from person to person so like you
said I don't think we're ever gonna be
able to get rid of them entirely just
because that's the nature of them Nostra
Thomas makes a prediction the Cure is
gonna be worse than the damn disease
locking people down a quarantine in
people could cause civil unrest probably
the damn best thing to do is just let
the [ __ ] spread and treat it as it goes
just take the casualties that's probably
what they're gonna do I don't know we
don't really have the don't know you
first rock gender that probably
infrastructure for what for I mean the
health care infrastructure it'll will
probably be overwhelmed in some place
yeah yeah I think you just I think some
people are gonna die but like I said you
know that's not an ideal situation no
but you know if you keep locking down
and putting quarantine so that could go
on for the next hundred years that'll
depress the economy that'll do all kinds
of stuff but if you just let it ride
it'll kill off from people and who knows
he might get heard resistance faster if
you did that
yeah we're hope there's really no way of
knowing and like I said it's you know
you just have to keep it from spreading
as far as you were able but you know you
can only do that up to a point
yeah cuz it gets to a point where we're
where it might end up being worse than
we're worse than it actually is just
letting it kind of spread a little bit
because if you keep walking down these
whole center's whole swaths of the
country will become non-functional their
economies will be destroyed the collapse
into like mad mad max pad pandemonium
you know and more people will be killed
in the collapse than they would by just
the
iris if you just let run most people get
this and it doesn't do anything to him
they get sick for a little bit and get
over it well we're just kind of hoping
that that's gonna happen for the
majority of people the worst they've
seen so far is Italy which was 8% but it
had a lot 8% fatality but it has a lot
to do with the demographics it was a
very old population that got hit yeah
you know if the demographics had been
different in that area well they
wouldn't have wouldn't have looked like
that it more commonly looks like 2% 3%
mostly people 60s 70s 80s that's most of
mostly 80s that's that's really where it
gets you and I just don't see them tear
in society apart over people in their
80s I just don't see it yeah I'm just
trying to be practical you know it's sad
but probably true well you know as I
said it's no one wants to see people die
obviously even their family members and
stuff like that but the thing about it
is that sometimes there's just a
seasonal flu will take out somebody
that's older yeah also yeah the seasonal
flu is doing it cancers are doing it all
other kinds of diseases are doing it the
numbers really aren't that big you know
I mean if you looked in the big scheme
of things you know it's not you're not
talking about 30 percent mortality
that's the [ __ ] strong disease there
well yeah and what was it
Spanish flu I think was about what 15 I
can't remember it was 15 percent fatal
but it's got to see how it goes just
mentally prepare yourself people yeah I
mean we'll see how it goes like I said
it's fairly normal around here still
yeah other than not being like I said we
might actually venture out just to go to
the liquor store and then come right
back yeah we'll see how it's going like
I said I went to Walgreens the other day
and see you in normal other than like
the tape on the floor and yeah it was
orderly loves and masks and stuff like
that so no ones like flipping out around
here
and they we you know we still have
steady food supply and stuff but but you
know like we mentioned before we live in
a sort of suburban area we don't we live
right in the middle of yeah we're in a
weir
we're out in the upper-middle class
suburbs in an enclosed well even Florida
in general even our vote downtown area
for two suburban yeah it's mostly yes we
have like downtown Orlando and yes we
have like downtown Tampa general litter
fairly large but a lot of people don't
live there like a lot of it's just like
businesses and office space and stuff
and most people live in like seven most
of our [ __ ] is like strip malls and
stuff like that was like large yeah
distances in between which is why you
know in Florida we do have some public
transportation like buses and stuff like
that but most people have cars because
if you don't have a car it is a pain in
the ass to get around just because
everything is so far apart do you know
what I mean yeah I was trying to tell
that to somebody online who's trying to
compare Florida the Florida to New York
there's no comparison we don't have any
Subway's we don't have any tall
buildings to speak of nobody lives in a
city just but yeah I mean some beep
people do but it's like it's not this
for you it's not the same kind of thing
it's like usually the downtown area is
mostly banks office buildings and
businesses and bars yeah bars clubs you
know restaurants stuff like that people
do live there but not that many it's
just just executives up in some yeah
outside the city just because Florida's
suburban it is largely suburban yes
suburban and rural farms yeah you know
you drive just ten minutes out this way
it's nothing but huge farmlands with one
house on it in a big ole pastures all
around it yeah especially around here
there's a lot of uh you know kind of
widely separated time stuff but um you
know so that's probably why it hasn't
really been all that weird around here
and weird population density isn't
popular population density is like
really light here I mean relatively
they're still like people and if you go
out it's like there's still traffic and
stuff but it's like it's not like a
[ __ ] that last time I would center
that last time I went to New York about
ten years ago I felt like I was
underground in some kind of
maximum-security prison that's how many
people there were I
New Yorker just [ __ ] people on top of
people and on top of people a little
bitty shopping carts I was very
uncomfortable there I didn't like it
well hell if you didn't like New York
have really not go to London because I
like London too
but it is very very crowded like
consider you know compared to like what
you're used to because like I said
Florida is like big large open spaces
largely well you know growing up part of
part of the time in Brazil you know I
was in Sao Paulo which is like one of
the largest cities in the world but it's
not crowded right it's spread well yeah
that's like what Florida cities are yeah
like a Florida City there's AK they're
very like widely spread out and and
Brazilians have space bubbles they don't
like to be up on people like that
they don't like that yeah you know it's
there they're kind of like southerners
everything spread out and he's chilled
out to like some Paloma does not did not
have an intense culture it was very
laid-back a very chilled out you know
it's almost kind of like Italy like a
well I don't know I heard they're pretty
I tense pretty intense I was trying to
see maybe what it would what it would
what it would compare to although I've
heard the drive did the driving how they
drive in Brazil they drive like Phoenix
when I got old a goddamn what do they
call it and worms
what worms in their brains that [ __ ]
scope I don't know it's time it's called
something you get they got a lot of it
down there it makes you a [ __ ] real
risk-taker what's the hell what the hell
is that [ __ ] Co I don't know that's just
a some Isis it's got one of the largest
incidences of that damn okay in the
world and I mean UK I'm just not talking
out of my ass you can you know I know I
just didn't know what you're talking
about in the 80s they had like the
largest incident of this [ __ ]
parasites that would get into your brain
you we didn't really kill you
alright but it makes act like a crazy
makes you act like a crazy person it
makes you one of the things that it does
is like one of the side effects is is
that the smell of cat urine is pleasing
to you if you have it interest a that's
one of the ways they tell if they have
it and they yeah I think it comes from
cat boxes or that's one of the places
but the thing is that the cats have to
be infected with it what the hell's that
[ __ ] called Jenni
I know I yeah now that you're like
toxoplasmosis okay tacos pun bunnies or
that's something else I think it's from
well you can check on Wikipedia but
Brazil had like one of the highest rates
of toxoplasmosis makes you a damn race
car driver makes you win it soccer makes
you a sex demon they don't they don't
have in abyssion same way you know okay
it's a little tiny microscopic worms of
the brain it's just kind of like our
limbs did Martha is there there are some
like parasites that get into like
various insects like ants and stuff and
they take over their brains in the brain
make the ant do you like what the
parasite wants them to do like mind
control toxoplasmosis that's [ __ ]
crazy toxoplasmosis created Carnivale
you know carneval oh there's another
[ __ ] right man that first Carnivale i
was i was a teenager and that [ __ ] went
on for like a week
yeah it's even even cameraman from the
television stations were [ __ ] up a lot
of TV you need be zooming in on some
girls ask guys behind the - camera we
get in front of the camera just like
some [ __ ] out of Star Trek Star Trek
episodes we're like well today is the
day where we all go [ __ ] batshit
crazy
what was that Star Trek episode then the
[ __ ] claw boom boom boom and and now
start [ __ ] killing each other just
for that one day that's the way like a
week like the purge yes it's like a
[ __ ] week that [ __ ] carnival it does
sound like a fun time yeah
I can't face the face with it one time
when I just saw a dude [ __ ]
staggering down the street with about
200 yards of ticker tape [ __ ] hanging
from him he look like a mummy it's
dragging on 200 yards of damn [ __ ]
coloured ticker-tape confetti he gets
into his car and pulls all of it in
there with it yeah it was up there I
mistaken that I got here know that all a
paper with it that was up to his [ __ ]
chimneys driving away in a car full of
[ __ ] ticker tape he was like driving
like
oh yeah I'm drunk that's straight-up
legal in Brazil yeah it does it doesn't
strike no it's illegal but it's just not
enforced I don't give a [ __ ] yeah if you
drunk sir I'm drunk I'm drunk off my ass
you got any more because the cops drink
alright Godspeed my side a cop's dream
I've seen cops drinking on duty in
Brazil the be in the bar [ __ ] doing
shots I'm gonna go out on a [ __ ]
enforce laws yeah in the 1980's Brazil
was a lot like the 1920s Richard yeah
you know men twenties and thirties is
about like that when I was there that's
pretty I mean it's [ __ ] wild
horrifying but also hilarious Society
collapsed and [ __ ] well my friends are
still there and they tell me about
what's going on and they were like dude
you were here during the good old days
yeah it's [ __ ] bad now it's worse than
Colombia ever was yeah yeah that there's
no guns but the murder rate is [ __ ]
sky-high
don't they have a highest murder rate in
the world yeah that them our guns are
illegal and they don't have very many of
them but they just [ __ ] kill each
other like it's nothing
maybe it's not maybe Brazil second I
can't remember it's number one hand it's
either number one owner because they
ever want yeah yeah you know that
[ __ ] they said well they need to
collect all those guns well who's gonna
who used to collect the guns are the
cops who do you think selling the guns
yeah the cops yeah you know the [ __ ]
use just once you have a society there's
just that corrupt yeah I mean you just
and then and you said that they don't
even really like not that they don't see
it as corruption but they're just ladies
you know
yeah oh wow yeah that's how it goes yeah
they kind of have that sort of college
HEU she chimneys the little way we had
these little ways yeah little ways of
doing things because they don't their
governments have basically been
illegitimate and unpopular forever so
they just kind of have a culture just
ignoring it yeah you know it's very
little [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] that what's
illegal
oh [ __ ] that I'm not doing that I don't
agree with that so yeah yeah so it's a
lot like a mirror episode from Star Trek
it's just like yeah that's where I come
from that's why
it turned out this way I mean you lived
there a long time yeah okay like if you
guys like Star Trek and [ __ ] go watch
Star Trek Enterprise in a mirror darkly
one and two from me that's the best
episode because that was like normal
yeah I was like yes we're supposed to be
right yeah but that [ __ ] in the paint
booth break him you know so that's just
understand that and then they're bribing
each other and [ __ ] and [ __ ] wearing
deaths head and [ __ ] [ __ ] they got
basically SS inside the [ __ ] the info
inside the enterprise SS troops in there
remember that secret police yeah yeah I
wasn't a big fan of enterprise but I did
like this new episode man it was a
badass episode yeah well didn't they
they did a mirror episode on the old one
tear right they didn't mirror episode
yeah because I think even though the
original episode that was the best one
yeah and then a [ __ ] Star Trek
continues you know the the web series
[ __ ] they did yes part two that's
right they did the mirror episode that
was really good man well because that
spot did mirror Spock yeah cuz that's
mostly like kind of everyone's favorite
probably in the top I have episodes Star
Trek ever yeah just but police Spock was
like super sexy like when you get evil
if you guys if you guys haven't seen
don't if you guys haven't seen what you
doing kid haven't seen Star Trek
continues on on YouTube you see for free
vic Mignogna Mignogna and all his
buddies do a [ __ ] Star Trek it's just
like it's like the third season of the
original episode it's [ __ ] exactly
pretty much exactly like yeah we did
like a review of it a long time because
it's like it's really really good like
yeah they did so much work out and a lot
of original people from the original
series work on it and it's the writing
is [ __ ] perfect it's just like from
that time and like Scotty's son plays
Scotty yeah they're sucking you know I
mean it's just pretty good man Vicky's
like the other he's like the other shat
to me that's that's the other Kirk a
two-point shot made Kirk you know that
yeah that's that's his character but Vic
channels that [ __ ] he comes that's Kurt
to
that's also Kirk a lot better than the
new Kirk off the damn movies well it's
like I like that actor but it's hard for
me because I've seen him in so many
other things that is not Kirk that it's
hard for me to like for him to disappear
into Kirk because I've seen him in so
many other that should have been Vic man
Jana playing it yeah cuz that that's
Kirk I mean I do have to say though that
like Spock is my very favorite yeah and
I like this Bach on the Star Trek
continues but it's like it's Todd I mean
yeah I mean Leonard Nimoy you can't
really he invented it you kind of
invented that character yeah so it's
like but I love the guy that's on there
yeah but you know that's all I can tell
you guys so I can just keep your [ __ ]
wired up when we go ahead and shut this
down we're gonna get some booze yeah we
got to run and get some booze and then
wash our hands a lot yeah we'll go to
the special booze place the special
booze yes you know talking about like in
the big boost or not Walgreen Sam Sam
Sam Jim okay so we gotta go okay I can't
remember names hopefully hopefully this
Sam store isn't a zoo Sam should be well
you see the the liquor store is separate
so I know it's like usually usually it's
not bad well you could just drop me off
if you want all running to get all right
yeah or we could just Park it does yeah
right we'll go up there and see what's
going on and then I probably will
probably report back on it tomorrow one
we record the shakeela we're out of
everything gonna keep I'm out of vodka
I'm out of whiskey either to keep my
toxoplasmosis now yeah well you know all
right so we I will talk to you guys
again tomorrow with another update